[Music]
they said to bring you goods in it so I
[Music]
[Music]
write my name Jim welcome to the farm
how are you baby you got on we've got
some decent well before you so grab your
bags we've got work to do so come on
I think I did well come on
falling for the first challenge we're
gonna gather some shape up why is that
one looking at men like that hey can I
was meant to be 35 there is only 34 so
if left one up there in the woods
somewhere so you're gonna have to go up
and get it
me we've been trying to find this Shiva
hours yo I'm lost
it's like 4:00 a.m. on my head towards
dad it was all raining earlier so mad
it's a good thing I got this jacket on
that my manga was his name Jim I'm sorry
give me this jacket or water-resistant I
thought he was one of some joke team but
it's nice though I like it
I respect this Jackie hey if I dad time
I want my lover in it as she nanana
scrap that I'm not moose
[Music]
alright guys here's your next challenge
you're gonna muck this penny on this
that's more fresh
good job today guys really well done
Tommy headed back to the farmhouse for a
cup of tea oh no no no you till you put
it up the hill I'll go back and put the
kettle off
[Music]
that's what is well here we are guys all
the challenges have come to an end huh I
wouldn't give up your day job
hey there was that clobber we gave you
to wait thanks very nice yeah